[Music]
for me it's important to make miniatures
just for preserving memories
my name is pre one I'm a miniature
artist I make miniatures for living in
color impor some of the places or
buildings they may be demolished in one
day this is why I think how many art can
be so meaningful this is not just a
model it's not just a miniature for
decoration when I see the old buildings
getting demolished very soon I decided
to make this piece so at least there are
models to see after it is really
demolished
it's Lawren Pongo is a bit hidden away
from the city all wrong
it is Malay but it means early early in
the morning you can see a lot of
uncle-aunty they'd love to go to the old
copy term to have a typical breakfast
this copy team has been assisting here
for more than 60 years back to a few
months ago I came here before they are
still some hidden shops inside which is
still opening but by this time when I
come here again they are closed within a
short period they are changing very
rapidly so I take the initiate to
recreate them before they are gone
[Music]
miniature art it is something in three
dimensions and when you recreate
something that is not existing anymore
after time and you look back to the
model you can see you can touch it
you can even feel it
I understand that a development of a
country is unavoidable
imagine you go forward 20 or 30 years
from now the youngsters may not able to
see all these buildings that still
remains the original it's slowly
disappearing what I can do is make it
miniatures so at least in the future
when you put it in the museum so people
can see that in three-dimensional way
that's why I come into miniature arts to
make them and recreate them to preserve
the memories
[Music]
you